alright let's talk about the latest in
sex toys and robot sex and iPhone sex
and all that good stuff there is a new
app and a new a vibrator called the
we-vibe 4 plus and basically the woman
has a vibrator that she's gonna stick in
her and her partner or her friend or a
friend of the family or whatever weird
[ __ ] you're into controls that app from
a remote location but don't take my word
for it we've got some video soon I can't
wait
are you ready to give this a try I've
been waiting all day
yeah that's that's real that's real
that's happening we've talked a lot
about robot sex and you know that often
the sex industry leads technology and
you know it obviously will work with
interracial couples also which is nice
any thoughts any thoughts Gina so I used
to really get annoyed when you know
people would talk about sex toys and the
man a man would always say well it's
just making penises obsolete like shut
up you're doing it right it's not
obsolete yeah you think so
yeah I mean look he didn't even have to
be there he feels like a man he's
turning up the volume he's going from
echo to vibrate to he doesn't have to be
there he feels like he's getting it done
so is there some weird thing you know
people always talk about the power
that's involved in sex and one side
always has more power and I guess
usually it's the man that this it really
seems like you're giving all the power
to the man I mean this woman could be
walking around with this thing in her
all day literally and this guy can just
be buzzing her at any point Jimmy do you
want one for your wife finally finally a
product for women who are too exhausted
to masturbate right I mean no that's
this has been a big problem I've read
the articles in the Cosmo and what have
you and they talked about I would like
to press on on my vibrator but I off
there was just an app that my husband
could do it from you know some kind of a
public place that would be fantastic
yeah it's ridiculous that's funny about
the way they did that too he's sitting
in the park so like he's just going
about his normal day she obviously is
home and this is one of those things
this is like just because you have the
technology doesn't mean it's worthwhile
yeah like I remember a guy who was a
drug dealer in my neighborhood and he
used he bought a Cadillac and he had a
remote control for his stereo in his car
cuz you could have it because you could
have you couldn't so you could have this
you could have an app on your iPhone in
terms on a vibrator inside your
girlfriend's [ __ ] but that's it's not
necessary it's just a bit much it's
exactly s remotely do it hey I'm sitting
at a fountain I wonder if I could get my
wife's [ __ ] hot what what
who what does that say when what just
gonna change is this gonna change the
conversations between like grandparents
and grandkids cuz oh the only thing I
can think of is in my day we actually
had to be there three flights of stairs
to stick a finger in a vagina yeah you
don't have that's actually a really
great boy because I always think about
that like oh my grandma passed away last
year and I saw these love letters that
my grandfather wrote to her and you know
when he was fighting in the war in World
War two and the stacks of love letters
and it's like cuz now that was a wire
that I went all the way to an
underground tunnels and 20 people died
my dearest love stop Sam here's there
really were telegrams too but really
like they had to have this long distance
it took time for literally the paper to
get across the world where now you can
meet someone on an app send to them
their dick pic they can send you the
boob pic right then and there like we
really are losing a little something
right I like the I like the hotel to do
that via telegram please don't stop stop
please stop don't stop stop stop
you know if maybe you live far away or
if you're into some kinky stuff do your
thing I would probably end up taking you
know the the D batteries out of a
flashlight sticking it in there going
about my day and texting later and
saying that was fantastic yeah yeah
wonderful
all right well actually we've got some
images of the device so that's what it
looks like so what's happening so just
to be clear what's happening there is
the bottom part is going into the vagina
and the top part is gonna stimulate the
clitoris and you've got modes you've got
vibrate you've got pulse wave echo and
tied Jeana you're the only one with a
vagina here these are the same modes you
get on the elliptical I like to jerk off
on an incline about you yeah it's really
if you could pick one exercise to do it
incline jerking I think that's an
Olympic sport I think yeah obviously you
go to the gym in West Hollywood
that's where I go that's our insiders I
go to all of them 24-hour Fitness which
is not 24 hours that's where I go it's
not 24 hours all right well anyway if
you get one of these messages in the
comments below and we'll I don't know
maybe we'll get one you won't run me out
hey I'll go stand over there by the TV
you guys go at it with the controllers
and I'll let you know how it goes